depuis le mois de juin les employés
ontariens des entreprises qui compte
plus de 25 employés ont droit à la
déconnexion et ne sont plus obligés de
répondre à leurs textos et à leurs
courriels le soir la fin de semaine et
certains aimeraient bien qu'on encadre
aussi les pratiques au québec c'est le
cas de notre invité à bille gerba et les
présidente de la jeune chambre de
commerce de montréal bonsoir madame
djerba bonsoir andré alors pourquoi le
droit à la déconnexion c'est un enjeu
qui est important pour la jeune chambre
de commerce mais écoutez leurs yeux est
la réflexion n'est pas nouvelle pour la
justice et aime ça fait déjà un moment
qu'on discute danger comme le bien-être
au travail ou la santé mentale direct le
droit à la déconnexion c'est un peu la
suite logique de la discussion avec la
pandémie le bureau il rentrait à la
maison l'avenir entre au bureau il est
lé travail a fait accélérer je dirais la
transformation numérique des entreprises
la transformation du milieu de travail
donc avec ce tout ce nouveau contexte la
barrière elle est maintenant floue entre
la vie privée l'année payer la vie
professionnelle puis juste un peu c'est
ça l'enjeu est là le besoin de justement
est à dire des balises claires
pourraient sortir de l'informel mais
dans la réalité le modem gerba est ce
qu'un employé ait vraiment réellement
tenus de répondre à ses courriels le
soir ou la fin de semaine ou ou est ce
qu'on n'en donne pas un peu plus souvent
par nous-mêmes mais c'est ça justement
l'enjeu c'est que présentement ça dépend
de chaque employé ça dépend de chaque
gestionnaire la réflexion que d'autres
pays on est que d'autres provinces on
sait justement de réfléchir et de ouvrir
la discussion pour que chaque entreprise
on est conscient qu'il veut pas être mur
à mur et qu'il se veut pas non plus
avoir une solution magique pour tous les
secteurs d'activité mais l'idée ici
c'est de lancer la discussion et que
chaque entreprise plus seulement par
l'eau s'est employé pour délimiter un
peu la langue qui est pareil pour tout
le monde ça dépend justement vous disiez
de chaque personne de chaque
gestionnaire est-ce que c'est
générationnel aussi on se pose la
question vous savez l'hyper connectivité
on a l'impression parfois que ça affecte
davantage les jeunes travailleurs les
chefs d'entreprise qu'est ce que vous
observez moi je crois pas que génération
de même je pense que n'importe qui qui
ont un téléphone intelligent peut être
une victime de l'hyper connectivité la
transformation du milieu de travail elle
a pas
échappée personnes l'idée ici c'est de
mettre des balises et des disques qui
était discuté de la limite chacune les
différentes chacun à une heure de
travail différent c'est vrai que je
pense que les plus jeunes ou sur une
transformation de la société les gens
sont de plus en plus content d'avoir la
flexibilité les gens travaillent
désormais différente donc tout le monde
veut travailler que leur salut à lui
plaît mais l'idée est de ne pas
traverser la ligne d autres nos
collègues et justement c'est un format
lité qui crée de la frustration au cul
créé d'aider les ennuis entre collègues
ou entre gestionnaires et employés d'où
l'idée d'encourager les organisations à
avoir des politiques sur le droit à la
déconnexion vous le mentionnez c'est
quoi les avantages pour un employeur de
rendre sa officiel les moments où il ne
peut pas joindre les membres de son
équipe mais c'est ça l'important c'est
de pas penser que le 3d connexion c'est
qu'est ce qu'on perd qu'est ce qu'on
gagne tout le monde est perdant
présentement avec le côté informel le
flou je parlais justement un employeur
récemment qui m'expliquait qui partent
en vacances mais que lui les que
déconnecté jamais et je sais de lui
faire comprendre que est ce que tu peux
pas ne pas déconnecter en tant que
patron envoie un mauvais message aux
employés qu'ils reculaient lundi que non
plus alors durant leurs vacances ne
ferait pas totalement déconnecté donc
les d'ex france c'est justement d'avoir
cette discussion là on est consciente
qu'une entreprise de servier c'est pas
la même chose qu'une entreprise
manufacturière entreprises avec des
clients locaux s'élargissent qu'une
entreprise avait des clients à
l'international mais l'idée justement
c'est de trouver une solution des idées
et avoir une discussion pour trouver des
surnoms en équilibre hautement n'est
confortable et vous disiez tout à
l'heure que la réflexion est en cours un
peu partout c'est la france qui est
partie le ballon une loi sur la
déconnexion là-bas depuis 2010 est au
portugal un employeur est même passée
d'une amende de 15000 dollars ses
contacts ses équipes hors des horaires
qui ont été convenues qu'est ce qu'on
apprend de ses expériences à
l'international mais c'est ça on peut
pas imiter ce que notre pays n'est fait
on peut pas copier coller le contexte
québécois est différente du contexte de
la france par contre on pourrait imiter
c'est la réflexion la discussion ça se
construit quelques compromis t on et
cela dit en pleine pénurie de main
d'oeuvre
peut-être que certains travailleurs
l'observent déjà avec leurs salaires par
exemple on s'est dans certains cas plus
facile de négocier la rémunération les
avantages alors à défaut d'une loi est
ce que les travailleurs devraient
eux-mêmes se permet de discuter de ces
balises la déconnexion avec les patrons
les employeurs mais c'est sûr que les
employeurs et les employés pourront plus
en plus le demander les négocier mais
c'est justement ce qu'on aimerait éviter
c'est que ce soit toujours au cas par
cas que 10 de l'organisation notamment
quand ils les joueurs turcs du
choisissent leur organisation avec leur
que la culture organisationnelle donc
libye et si c'était justement de invité
les gens dans notre organisation pardon
et de les indices qui justement voici
nos politiques voici ce qu'on attendait
vous voici que quand vous on comprend
que vous pouvez déconnecté dont
justement éviter ce flou donc on veut
éviter le cas par cas et que chaque
employé dépendre de chaque gestionnaire
de chaque entreprise parce que ça finit
par être lourd évidemment les pères
connectivité il ya des études des coups
de sonde qui ont été menées très
récemment qui montre que par exemple un
travailleur sur trois présente des
signes de détresse psychologique au
canada c'est la dépendance aux
téléphones intelligents qui comptent
pour beaucoup mais ça s'ajoute au stress
l'anxiété de la pandémie du télétravail
la gestion des affaires
votre position par rapport à ça madame
gerba
chiffres les banques même nous on
s'entre nos membres et on le voit les
gens sont de plus en plus connectés les
gens font de plus en plus d'heures et
les gens ne savent plus où est la ligne
entre le travail et la vie personnelle
donc je pense que c'est pour ça
justement qui à cette urgence d'avoir un
petit débat et je pense que honnêtement
l'assemblée nationale serait le meilleur
endroit pour les débuter pour justement
éviter d'avoir un flot délaissé chaque
employé où chaque employeur dépend un
peu de son contexte et son secteur
d'actifs alors on retient les conseils
que vous nous avez donné madame gerbe on
espère qu'ils resteront à l'esprit de
ceux qui partent en vacances dans les
prochaines heures merci beaucoup d'avoir
été leur fait plaisir mais ça vous pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne ici et redit